from the moment she was born she was
pretty much a miracle baby they told me
I'd never have another baby after that
accident and we wanted her very much
and she was beyond anything we ever
could have hoped for it how's this for
mother-daughter goals 20 year-old Emily
starting her own music career she's an
accomplished drummer and singer she's
all good with mom calling the shots
directing her video and Gloria is fine
with her little girl um swearing
we can't even tell you the title of
Emily's first single the funny part is
she has never cursed in her entire life
not entirely no now is different but I
would invent my own camera yeah she
would make up words and I take once
you're 18 then you could say whatever
you want but that doesn't look nice or
cute in the voice of a child and they
never neither one of them ever and ever
no just good yeah show me something
now that's gone to hell in a handbag
with your name Emily Emily hi Gloria
first introduced us to six-year-old
Emily at the 2001 Grammys we even
witness Em's first day of college today
she's rocking the same thick eyebrows
and curls gloria did in the 80s and as
for words of advice from her mom i don't
you just be yourself be who you need to
be I mean it's really hard
how am I supposed to top the medal of
freedom all that stuff I'm not gonna
follow that path I'll just admire it and
go the other